[Music]
so
now let's dive into the best practices
for
developing shiny apps
um so actually you can build apps that
last and in my talk i'm going to cover
two areas which is
organizing a shiny up code organizing
your development environment
and organizing your testing since we
have limited
amount of time um this will be a high
level overview talk
and i'm going to introduce concepts and
tools you should be using
and tell you why so if you are not
familiar with them you can explore them
in more details after the talk
so how should you organize the code
inside your shiny app
first answer is use shiny modules
so shiny modules let you decompose your
application uh so you can follow
uh don't repeat yourself a coding
principle they offer encapsulation
modularity reusability and
allow you to test the whole components
they allow you to organize your app in a
server and the ui part
which in essence mean that you can
define
your own pair of server and ui logic
and use it inside your app or embed it
in the other module um
so secondly you can also
organize your code using r6 classes
and an r6 class is a modern and fast
and simple implementation of orient or
object-oriented programming
in art you can look at it as a more
organized uh shiny module and r6 classes
introduces a clear system of getting
the current at the current state of the
piece of the functionality
the operations that can be performed
with it the auxiliary functions
and the initial state of the object that
can depend on the particular user rights
which might be uh actually super useful
so how do you organize your code
using r6 classes so you can keep each
class in a separate script
with a name similar to the class name
you can
store the scripts in a folder uh
separated
from the other code uh you can import
the code
um using a package or as in
here in an example using a use function
from the modules package or and
then you can initialize the class with
a new method which is automatically
automatically available
for all the classes and attach it to
some objects
and um the
the first option is to use um
modules from the honey and
i would like to avoid some confusion
with shiny modules
so um the modules i'm going to talk
right now
is something completely different from
shiny modules
and so the modules are the
organizational unit
for the source code and they can contain
shiny modules or essex classes or
just functions you define and the cool
thing about
them is that they enforce rigor when
defining the dependencies
it means that you have to explicitly
declare
which functions or packages
your code is using and you have to
import them
and you also have a full control uh of
the things that
are um available outside the module
because you have to export them
uh using the export function as shown
here in the
example and additionally they have a
local search path and they can be used
as subunit within the package
or in script so to put it all together
shiny modules are six classes and
modules
so shiny modules they let you reuse ui
and
server parts as a components r6 classes
they let you build objects that have a
single responsibility
and implement given logic and for honey
modules
they encapsulate dependencies and let
you organize
uh files that could be shiny modules and
r6 classes
as a separate units so okay
uh we covered uh how you organize the
code so
not now let's talk about the development
environment and um how you can
organize it so
um continuous integration to ensure
quality and automate checks
you can run lint and test automatically
for every push
change and especially for tests you
probably will forget to run them every
time
so just automate it so you don't think
you don't have to think about
it and additionally you can
automatically add
a pull request template that can contain
a checklist for a pull request creator
and the reviewer
to every pull request you can push
you can block pushing directly to master
and block
pull requests merging pull requests
if the tests fail
so here are some popular continuous
integration options
bitbucket circle ci travis jenkins
and github actions so i'm sure you will
find something that will
that will fit your technology stack
and remember uh you don't have to start
from scratch
every time and you can start you can use
a project
uh template for it so at epsilon we have
an
internal project pattern with a shiny
boiler
boiler
plate template and we use it to
initialize the repository structure
if we start a new project and it
contains a simple
shiny app with modules and
shiny modules set up it also fits a
sample
unit test and the ci with
length and automatic units tests set up
okay so how actually your um
development environment should look like
uh so let's start um
from uh from the other way so what
happens if you
don't uh take care of it uh so um
development environment is a crucial
part of working in art
and it's not only shiny specific so
um otherwise if you don't um take care
of it
you can end up with the same code giving
different
results on different machines other
projects can be affected
as in the global environment shirt
package can change
and crash unrelated project you can
imagine the deployment
is long and difficult as establishing uh
infrastructure is challenging if it's
not being tracked
and last but not least team will waste
time setting up a new environment
rather than jumping straight to work so
this might not be a problem when you're
starting a project but imagine
that you have to urgently add a new team
member
in the middle of one so
to solve all those problems um we
recommend um
a following setup so you can do a
development
uh in in rstudio running inside a docker
container
which is fixed and dedicated per project
and you can leverage docker and
rent package to control underlying
system system dependencies and our
packages
and docker and friends together make a
team collaboration easy
so all the changes to docker file and
run log file
that records the packages used in the
project
are committed um to the docker hub
repository
and to the code repository um for
example github
that your team is using
on the other hand the previous solution
still requires
um some level of devops skills and
what we observe with our clients
especially the enterprise one
um they choose to work with our studio
server pro that allows their data
science team
to purely focus on delivering value
using their core
competencies in a highly secure and
flexible environment
obviously here you still want to use
rent to control the our dependencies
and keep them separate for every project
so different team members can easily
collaborate
so the last bit um i'm going to talk
is testing and
my message
sorry and my message here is just
do it the only question is what tests
and in what proportion
you should be writing and um we will use
a testing pyramid
to answer that so you should aim to have
the most unique tests and data
validation the next
um test up components aka
test your shiny modules test the whole
scenarios with end-to-end testing
perform load tests and finally test
usability with user interest views
and now let's quickly talk about the
tools you have available
um
so for unit tests i'm sure you all know
the test the package
so just use it but please set up your
architecture early
and don't tell yourself an excuse that
you would do it later
because that will probably won't happen
because your
shiny application would be awesome and
your clients or your business partners
would like to move on to something else
so start each project with test
architecture
i you already know that you can have a
project template
uh to set up at the beginning you also
know that
you can use a continuous integration to
triggers
uh the test automatically so you don't
have to do it
manually and please write at least some
tests for each piece of code
and it would be easier to extend them
later
um and obviously keep your standard
standards high so do not accept pull
requests that
don't include uh tests or actually break
them
so um now
it's part for a data validation and this
is
the this is the logic this is the
um functionality that you should be
doing
on the same level as the unit tests so
as we
all know from our experience data can be
very messy and actually kind of users
reported that
this is their biggest bang the dirty
data
so i want to introduce you to a data
validator package
which is a tool for creating reports uh
based
on our opens i assert our
results and it allows you to create
user-friendly reports
that can be generated automatically for
example with
rstudio connect
so how can you use data validator
package in production
here's the uh example uh workflow
so you can run rstudio a connect
schedule directly
and the scheduler can source the data
from a database and
validates the results
based on the validation results a new
data validator
report is created and we have two
scenarios here so the validation fails
in that case a report can be sent to a
responsible
stakeholders so a responsible person
can actually take action and fix things
and obviously on the other hand we also
have positive scenarios so everything is
great
so the shiny app can be refreshed
with the new data
um and the the next step that i'm
gonna cover is amps and testing so the
face when you are actually uh testing
the full
uh components in your app and luckily we
have the
shiny test package from our studio and
that it's easy to use for developers you
can
record the scenarios and it provides a
quick and simple way to test your shiny
apps
on the other hand for more complex apps
we recommend
using cyprus but
please be aware that it requires
knowledge of javascript but it's really
really powerful
and we reached the point
that your application actually is ready
uh to go live so you want to make sure
that it's able
to uh handle the traffic so here
you can use shiny load test package that
enables you
to load test your deployed apps
you can estimate how many users your app
can support
you can identify bottlenecks and you can
use the test
output to guide you through the changes
if
the if the optimization is actually
necessary
okay and the the last bit that you
really have to think about
so you also want to make sure that what
you're actually
building is useful for your users so um
so please talk to them and you don't
need to have
a big budget to do that um because you
can
always use the hallway tests and the
idea here is that
um you can show the application to your
colleagues or to end users
and let them click through it and they
can describe what they are doing
and what they understand is happening
and research showed that if you
do it to five people you will learn
uh around 85 percent of the usability
problems and obviously if you don't do
it at
all you will learn zero problems
so the things i want you to take home
organize
your code with shiny modules r6 classes
or modules
depending on app complexity use ci to
run
lint and tests use rent to control
our dependencies and automate
code testing and data validations
thank you very much
[Music]